I want to congratulate you your show
people love your new show masters now
and they really do it's getting print
and you did something that I think took
a lot of guts I would not have been able
to do this you put your parents on your
show yeah and so you are working with
your parents I would find that I love my
parents don't get me wrong absolutely
love him but I don't know that I would
want to work with them all the time how
is it working with your parents it was
good they and it did a fantastic job but
you are working with your parents and
it's not it wasn't a small cameo they
were there for a while like they were in
New York for like two weeks right which
is a long time to be around your parents
when you're a guy in his 30s like I can
do like three days max right and then
after three days it's like alright I can
no longer maintain this facade okay you
failed I'm kind of a shitty person what
is it about what is it about yourself
that you feel like you have to maintain
what's what's hard - what's hard to keep
up besides just being polite
well one weird thing that happened was
so my parents there are little religious
they're Muslim and they don't eat pork
man I eat pork because I'm not religious
and and it tastes very tasty and I'm not
really so it's not a big deal but if I'm
around my parents I don't eat pork
because it feels weirdly disrespectful
or something so if they're around I
normally don't eat against their
religious beliefs so yeah you don't want
to do it around me yeah but then they're
in town for two weeks which is a longer
period of time and something happened
Conan why not shoot this is the place to
talk about it as ease we can we can help
you what happened so I go out to dinner
with my parents
and my girlfriend my girlfriend orders a
dish that has pork in it she doesn't
know about any of this stuff and she
gets the dish and I see I'm like Lou
that looks pretty good I kind of want a
bite and then I'm like oh no I can't
take a bite I'll get into a tea with my
parents I can't do that and then I'll
let you know this is silly I'm 32 years
old I can do whatever I want it's not a
big deal and so I grab a bite and then I
mom's like what are you doing and I was
like I'm eating noodles
like this poor kid those noodles eat
pork and I was like yeah 32 in a doodle
war they were they were both upset my
mom was upset and my dad was upset
visibly upset but we didn't talk about
it cuz we're Asian people and we don't
discuss our emotions right so then a
great great facet yeah
religion yeah and then and then so then
we uh we a couple days later me my
girlfriend are out in New York and we
grab a bacon egg and cheese sandwich or
walking around street and I'm not making
this up this is a hundred percent true
we run into my parents on the street and
they're like what are you guys up to and
I'm like I'm headed this meeting she's
going to the park and then I go we'll go
with her to the park and then we'll all
get together later I'm like perfect and
then my dad before I walk away is like
Luke can have a bite of that sandwich
and I was like no there's pork in it
okay he's like alright fine and then
they leave and about ten minutes later I
get a text with my girlfriend and the
text says your parents are asking me why
I'm forcing you to eat pork
they said you'd never ate pork until I
came around they're asking me why I'm
peer pressuring you into eating pork and
I felt awful I felt really bad so I
wrote her back right away and I said ha
ha ha that's hilarious and so the way
this whole thing kind of ended was we
went out for one more dinner
he's like our last dinner the four of us
together and my girl was like don't
order any stuff with morganite there's
no reason to like ruffle their feathers
and I was like no it's a matter of
principle okay I'm 32 years old I can do
whatever I want and so I order a dish
for dinner my mom's like really and I'm
like yeah look I'm 32 I can do what I
want I'm not religious I made that
choice that's fine
you know I don't tell you what to do you
don't tell me what to do we're adults
she's like all right and it was it was
tense and then um at a certain point my
girlfriend gets up and goes to the
restroom and I just looked at my parents
and I was like help she's making me eat
pork
[Applause]
now I'm in the clear everything's okay
hey thanks for watching be sure to click
subscribe to see even more great Conan
clips you may now return to your pirated
movies and creepy Japanese pornography